when I say work hard I don't say work  hard and burn out people are making  assumptions out here they took a word I  used to love called hustle which meant  work hard and we've manipulated into  this world of like oh if you do that  you're doing drugs and alcohol and have  mental health issue that's crazy I'm the  most chill calm person on Earth I'm so  content and happy I'm chill as [ __ ] I  sleep seven eight nine hours a day I'm  calm as a cucumber that's because I'm in  my zone and my zone is to be a [ __ ]  entrepreneur operator for people that  aren't they shouldn't because it's  [ __ ] anxious if I was my incredible  admins I'd be anxious I don't like  getting everything right and making sure  everything's running on time I'd be  fired in project management within a  week at vaynermedia a week or maybe I  would quit in 48 hours